hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast new approaches to
antibody validation and targeted protein
quantitation using mass spectrometry
presented by dr. John Rogers we're
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo fisher scientific
thermo fisher scientific incorporated is
the world leader in serving science we
help our customers accelerate life
sciences research solve complex
analytical challenges and improved
patient diagnostics and increase
laboratory productivity I'm Kristina
jewel of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for it at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem I would like to now introduce
our speaker dr. John Rogers John Rogers
is a senior rmd manager at thermo
scientific where he manages the
development of new reagents and kits for
protein mass spectrometry research John
has an undergraduate degree in
biochemistry and computer science and a
PhD in pharmacology from the University
of Washington John managed a
bioinformatics group at Pfizer and a
proteomics group at abbott before
joining the thermo fisher scientific
team in 2007 since joining thermo john
has led the development of new ms
standards and calibrate protein sample
preparation reagents and reagents for
quantitative proteomic analysis
including tandem mass tag reagents
please join me in welcoming dr. John
Rogers I will now turn the presentation
over to him
after Rogers High thank you for the kind
introduction and I want to thank
everybody for joining this webinar I
look forward to to hearing how you what
do you think of it I look forward to any
questions I think you'll find that it's
a we've taken a new approach to how we
validate our antibodies using some tools
that we've developed and some novel
applications so I want to just talk a
little bit about what we're going to
describe what I'm going to describe
today some background on antibody
validation and some approaches that have
been promoted in the literature in the
last few months around pillars of
antibody validation and then we'll talk
about how we how we choose our cell
lines for verifying an antibody how we
screen those those cell lines and
antibodies using mass spectrometry and
then how we analyze the data so I so I
again I welcome you to to participate in
any way that you choose we'd love to
answer questions so there is a critical
need for validation of antibodies you
know whether we look at how much time is
wasted or how much money is wasted the
problem is is we draw conclusions based
on the value of these Hannah based on
the properties of these antibodies and
sometimes if the antibodies aren't well
characterized it may actually result in
incorrect conclusions and so we want to
help our customers be successful in
their work and we also want to help them
be successful in in how they how they
get their funding so it turns out next
year in 2017 a number of funding
agencies and major journals will begin
requiring details about how the antibody
reagents used in those in that research
how we're were characterized and we want
to help our customers with that so the
way we approach this is to follow the
guidelines so in September of 2016 in
nature methods this paper was published
it was a proposal for a validation of
antibodies and it describes five pillars
this paper was was written by a an ad
hoc working group called this
international working
group 4 antibody validation or IW Gav
and they they described five pillars of
antibody validation these include
genetic orthogonal ax t correlation
tagging and immuno precipitation to mass
spectrometry so in genetic approaches
will have a protein is expressed in a
given cell line and we'll knock down the
gene using crisper casts or SI RNA and
we'll show that will show that that
signal is specifically reduced with
orthogonal ax t we may have a Western
blot across a variety of cell models or
silk cell lines and then we'll have some
other method like analyzer or mass
spectrometry measurement that shows high
correlation between the Western blot and
the orthogonal method in a third example
we might have two antibodies one that's
very well characterized as antibody one
and we have another antibody that we we
don't understand very well and we want
to understand and so will will show the
comparison and if they're highly
correlated will be able to say that
we've correlated antibody to based on
antibody one in a third man in a fourth
method we can use a recombinant
expression system so we can tag a given
target for a foreign antibody and say
and show that the tag cold my grades and
it's as specific as the antibody against
the given given a overexpress protein so
so these are all examples of pillars for
antibody validation that were proposed
by this working group they in the
article they also describe the
immunoprecipitations as a powerful tool
for validation but frankly they provide
little or no data they refer to a
previous paper on antibody validation
using that spec but they don't give a
lot of God a lot of guidelines for how
one might qualify an antibody so of all
of these so we're going to talk about
that so of all of these five pillars
it's important to note that only you me
no precipitation with mass spectrometry
can truly identify the target I
identify off targets can identify
interacting proteins and can identify
protein modifications so it's really the
most powerful and flexible tool illness
of this toolbox and I want to talk more
about how we use it so the approach that
we've taken is outlined in this song in
the summary slide we're going to walk
through each of these steps in more
detail so the first step that we in the
process was to select our targets to
what are the what proteins do we care
about and then what antibodies do we
have in our in our catalog the second
step was knowing those targets let's
identify the right cell line so it turns
out that not every protein is expressed
in every cell and so we have to choose
the right cells we analyze those cell
lines by mass spectrometry and then once
we've identified the right cell lines
and shown that we can see the proteins
we then immuno enrich those proteins
with a given antibody we analyze those
samples by mass spec and we analyze that
data using some some bioinformatic tools
and we'll talk in much more detail about
each of these steps so the first step
was how do we choose our genes so in
this case we went to the library and we
asked the library to do a search here
within thermo to do a search for how
many how many times of a given protein
was referenced in the literature and
then we summed the number of references
and turns out that p53 was the mo had
the most sub most citations in PubMed in
the PubMed database and it's very steep
it tails off very quickly and then it
goes out very long so a lot of proteins
are you know our report a very little in
the literature and there's a small
subset that are the focus of most of our
research and so we decided to start with
that prioritized list we then took that
that list of the top thousand proteins
in the literature we also added a couple
of things on so thermo scientific it
sells some kits called ion am placing
panels there the next-gen sequencing
panels in which they have pcr primers
that
amplify regions of particular genes
important for cancer or genetic disease
and they and then they've used next-gen
sequencing to sequence across the
regions that are prone to mutation so we
felt that these proteins may also be
interesting given their importance at
the genetic level we then shows cell
lines so we started with the NCI 60 and
looked at RNA expression data we also
looked at proteomic databases that are
available online proteomic stevie and
others and frankly we found the RNA
expression data to be more comprehensive
to cover those it ended up being about
1,300 protein targets we had some cell
lines that we had used in some of the
development of our kid some kits that we
we've made there are imbue no
precipitation of mass spec kits and we
had some cell lines we'd use to evaluate
some faculty development efforts that we
have we've we've had underway so we had
a variety of different cell lines and
then we use mass spectrometry to look at
these cell lines so as I'll describe the
next slide we chose twelve different
cell lines that represent a variety of
different variety of different cancer
types and we grew those cells we lice
the cells we prepared the proteins and
digested to peptides and they we
analyzed those peptides either
unfractionated straight from the lysate
or we fractionated the peptides with
some high pH reverse phase spin columns
and identified and quantified all of
those proteins so so this this slide
just shows the represented some
representative data so in this case we
took the 22 genes that are on the ion
amp lisi colon and lung cancer of panel
so the 22 different proteins known to be
important in colon and lung cancer and
we looked at the RNA expression data so
this is all available online you know
public available databases and the red
shows the overexpression relative to the
to the median occur
across all cell 0 NC I 60 cells so if
I'm looking for b-raf it looks like I
really need to look in s KMEL cells if
I'm looking for beta katina and I have a
couple more choices so we went through
and I said we identified 12 cell lines
that based on RNA data should express at
least ninety percent of those 1,300
proteins so then we analyze those by
mass spectrometry so we isolated the the
protein digested fractionated and
identified those proteins so here are
the five least similar cell lines the
data from five of those so a Venn
diagram so a549 so a lung cancer a
breast cancer a different breast cancer
a prostate cancer and a liver cancer are
represented around this Venn diagram and
across these five cell lines we saw
3,600 proteins across all five but
within each one of those cell lines we
saw an additional five you know a
thousand or more unique proteins from
each of those cell lines so we used this
combination of RNA and protein data to
characterize these 12 cell lines and so
if we look at just a brief summary of
around 80 different targets that are
important in cancer oh if I looked at
the unfractionated lysate by mass
spectrometry the green represents the
proteins that we saw and the Reds are
the proteins that we did not see but
after we fractionated so that we could
go deeper into the proteome we were much
more successful so there were relatively
few proteins that we were not able to
see with with with mass spectrometry and
those maybe a baby that we need to find
another cell line or more to capture
some of those so once we've identified
these cells and the proteins expressed
by them we can start comparing them so
here's an example of two proteins that
are important in the epithelial to
mesenchymal transition in cancer so cdh1
Soyka Darren and cdh to
cat hiren and if i look at the
unfractionated license i could detect
cat urine one in three different cell
lines hct116 will call in a prostate and
a and a breast cancer and you'll notice
because of the they're important for
that transition they're relatively well
the complementary expression profile of
n-cadherin so they're they're definitely
expressed in unique cells if i look at
the fractionated live sites now i can
begin to see let's say a549 i can see
both some ke khet hiren and n ket here
in the cat here and one and two so some
of the things we learn from this is that
there is no single cell line that
expresses both of these very well but we
do find some expression in a few cell
lines and if i had an antibody that was
directed against a pan cad hearing so
against all cad hirons i may have to
look at multiple cell lines or multiple
cell models to verify the targets so
once we've identified all of these
proteins we then process the data
through a software package called max
kwan this is a freely available software
program from the Max Planck Institute
and not only can it identify the
proteins in a mass spectrometry data set
but can also quantify those and so we
can have three different samples we can
analyze those separately by mass
spectrometry and then we can compare the
mass spec high-end chromatograms to look
at the relative protein expression
across those three different samples so
in this case we're looking across 12
different cell lines asking about the
expression of close to 15,000 proteins
and so for this for the studies that
we're going to describe that I'm going
to describe here we've used a metric
called protein l fq which stands for
protein label-free quantitation or
quantitative value so here's here's an
example where we looked at all of their
proteins that were expressed in mcf-7
and quantified in this case by l fq so
the
the log scale plot of the most highly
expressed to the least highly expressed
detected protein and across that
distribution we can see the cut here in
one was you know midway along that
distribution if i look at the
unfractionated versus the fractionated
we just simply went deeper and so the
cat here and moves into the more it's
more its expression is higher relative
to a larger set of proteins so we we can
compare these cell lines and what we've
done has chosen cell lines for our
studies in which the target was near or
below the median our concern is that in
some cases people or companies validate
their antibodies using cell lines that
overexpress the target and we believe
that that's a an inappropriate model for
validation so we want to test our
antibodies in real-life situations and
so we're choosing cell lines based on
the protein expression values so here's
an example of a set of ten antibodies
against p53 so here's the protein LF q
values so it's sort of a unitless
quantitation this label-free
quantitative value and we can see some
variation between the different
antibodies and the capture of be 53 so
in this case we've normalized this so we
use the same amount of antibody we use
the same amount of beads we use the same
amount of lysate and so one of the
questions that we're trying to answer is
whether the dif different intensities
has indicates some difference in
affinities of these antibodies but all
of these are validated on our website
they're already listed on website as IP
validated and all of them were confirmed
using our immunoprecipitations of mass
spectrometry approach so one of the
issues with with the mass spec is that
it sees everything you know as opposed
to a Western blot or an Eliza we can't
use a blocking agent we can't put milk
on it or BSA we have to figure out how
to deal with all of the proteins that
are in a sample that we can detect by
mass spectrometry and so the approach
that we've taken is to use this very
simple scatter plot and I'm just going
to I'm going to walk through this so if
i have an antibody against target one
that i want to understand i want to
characterize what what is a capture and
what things come along in the
immunoprecipitated sample i can then i
can compare it to a control IP to a
different antibody that's maybe a
different target but ideally it's
isotype matched so i'll do an immune of
precipitation with these two different
antibodies and I'll quantify the
proteins that were enriched with that
immunoprecipitation and I can plot their
LF q values so on the x and y axes I
cannot look at the relative amount of
each protein okay and if I plot it on XY
scale with the XY scale so in the Y
dimension I've got the protein
expression with my target antibody on
the x-axis the protein expression level
or the you know in the IP with the
negative control antibody what we find
is that all of the abundant or all of
the non specific proteins are in cod
that are in common are pulled into the
diagonal and this plot allows me to very
easily see the proteins that are
specific versus nonspecific so these are
all non specific proteins and these are
all specifically captured proteins with
my antibody ok so we've look at that
data and it's still a little bit too
complex so then we took the next step so
back in back when I was in grad school
and and early on I was
I used to purify a lot of proteins and
we characterize the performance of our
purification by a calculation of fold in
Richmond so we do the same thing with
our immunoprecipitations so we've
quantified our target in a whole cell
lysate we've quantified that same target
on in our IP so we can ask what's the
relative enrichment of my protein in my
immunoprecipitated sample versus that
target protein in the whole cell lysate
and so that's shown here on the on this
on this graph bifold enrichment so what
is what's shown here is this is an
antibody against ket here in 1 and cat
urine one is right here at the top of
the enriched specifically enriched a
protein list and it's colored in green
based on this color scale showing that
it's about 50-fold enriched but you can
see that if i had not subtracted those
abundant proteins the the head here and
one would have been masked by some of
these abundant sticky proteins that are
commonly seen and overwhelmed the signal
intensity but are really of there really
offering no information they're just
background proteins so we use this
approach this combination of a scatter
plot or you know it's similar methods to
subtract background proteins non
specific proteins and then we use the
folding Richmond approach to actually
quantify how much at the target this was
how well the target was enriched what's
interesting is that not all of these
other dots are gray some of them are
bluish so the cat here in one was 50
fold enriched and there are some other
proteins that were enriched at lower
levels so if i just take this section of
the graph and just take this region and
blow it up in the next slide as a bar
graph we're going to explore this a
little more so what's shown here are the
same list of protein
means in the previous slide but now
expressed as a bar graph and so if I
take this list of proteins and I paste
them into a website called string org so
this is a publicly available database of
protein interaction information i can
paste this list in to the string
database and it will the string website
and it will return a diagram of the
known protein interactions in the public
domain and what you can see in the
center of this is CAD here in one and
then you can see of a number of other
proteins that surround it that are known
to be important protein interaction
partners so we then color the color of
the chart to represent the target of
interest so in this case the red is ket
here in one the target of our antibody
and the blue lines are the enriched
proteins that are known interactors
based on public databases so i think
what's really most important about this
data set is not only do we verify the
target but we also verify that as
function that the antibody is
functionally capturing known protein
interactions and it was really valuable
here is that we are not capturing an
over expressed protein and we're not
catching tagged proteins we are
capturing the actual protein target out
of a normal cell line and its
interactions with no interferences with
no interferences like an interactive eat
a geezer these are native protein
interactors and i think this is really
valuable this is going to provide really
valuable insights and information
certainly provides much more detail
about the quality of an antibody so as
we analyze that data i can plug that
into other other tools like there's a
there's a tool called david or ease that
will calculate gene ontology
richmond and so you can see that we've
enriched a variety of of katina and or
beta beta catenin or cat here in
complexes and diagrammatically you can
see how well the enrichment of maps to
known complexes so i think we have some
really valuable information that comes
out of the mass spectrometer so we can
then start to look at more complicated
systems that would be very difficult to
validate by a western blog or crisper
Cass so as an example we have an
antibody a pan specific antibody to
adherence and we can see that get here
in four and and one and two are all
enriched and those are the red because
it was the target and then we see some
direct interactions like beta K beta
catenin and then we system interact it
some indirect where they're a little bit
further out around the periphery and so
we've in this figure we've just
highlighted them slightly differently
but what's really interesting here is
that we saw another protein called trim
9 this is tripartite motif and so we
asked well if ket here in is ket here in
for is enriched 82 fold and cut herons
or other kid here in journ rich 30 fold
why is trim 9 and rich 53 fold and so we
asked that question and frankly the easy
way to do it was we typed it into a web
search into a Google search so we just
typed in trim 9 and cat hiren and when
we did that first pay first paper that
came up or right in the top of the list
was a paper from 10 years ago where a
bio informatics group had analyzed the
trim family and identified up the trim 9
as a term 9 as a subset of the trim
family that contains a cat here and
domain so this is consistent with a pan
cat here in antibody capturing a
supposed off target but it's actually
real because it has a cat here in domain
as another example we can cross validate
so we saw beta-catenin come down with
the cut here and antibodies so now we
can capture with a with an antibody
against beta-catenin and see if we can
capture cat hearing so in this example
we compare a variety of antibodies to
beta catenin looking at their LF q
values across a number of different
antibodies not all of these listed the
antibody as web in this case all of them
were listed on their web as IP validated
and we we saw all of the targets but you
can see the intensity is very quite a
lot so we're still trying to understand
that the cause of that but definitely
identifying the target verifying the
target what's interesting though is that
if we then compare the results of these
antibodies well first let's let's just
take one so here's here's one of those
antibodies the one with the highest
expression level we can see beta-catenin
was enriched about 180 fold we see a
number of other protein interaction
partners in this blue or purple color
and one of them is a pc that was
enriched three hundred fold well that
kind of surprised us and so we did a
little bit more digging and it turns out
that APC has 11 beta-catenin binding
motifs in its sequence and frankly it's
very hard to see a pc in the cell line
until a fiend it by mass spec but after
enrichment with beta catenin antibody
now the APC is very easily seen very
high sequence coverage of clearly highly
enriched so it captures so this antibody
not only captures beta-catenin it
captures known come complex partners
like a pc as well as alpha catenin and
let's see i know we've got so good to
some cut hearings in here yeah cut here
in one and three right here
they're relevant and we can cross
validate our results another interesting
thing we can do is show complementarity
of all those antibodies so what I'm
showed here showing here is the fold
enrichment of each of those interaction
partners that came down so we have beta
catenin and then we have the partners
that were Co immunoprecipitated and
quantified by mass spectrometry so we
have a PC we have cdh 3 and 10 and on
down the list and so if I if I just by
looking at this I'm actually supporting
another another antibody validation
pillar which is complementarity I'm
showing a similarity of my mass spec
data across a variety of antibodies I
can map all of these into the end of the
interaction network like I've shown
previously and then I can actually start
to cluster the folding enrichment
information and I get some really
interesting results so what's shown here
is in this case we had 14 different
antibodies against beta-catenin and
there were some antibodies that enriched
most let me change my icon here we had
some antibodies that enriched one set of
proteins I changed my color
was one cluster I have another set of
antibodies that enrich a different
cluster and one antibody that actually
grabbed all of them all of the known
interaction all of the the largest
superset so we actually see a very
strong correlation between the
antibodies but we also see some
uniqueness between those antibodies
suggesting that these different
antibodies may interact with the
beta-catenin in some unique way
suggesting there may be some unique
epitopes and we could actually classify
those those those epitopes using the
mass spec results so just in summary I
hope I've convinced you that the
immunoprecipitation to mass spectrometry
is a key pillar in this IW Gav of
approach of recommendation so what I've
shown you is that we can verify the
target and identify known either off
targets that were you know that we can
explain or understand we can a we can
characterize pan specific antibodies we
can characterize you know we're working
on anti PTM directed antibodies so this
is a very powerful approach to
validating an antibody as as you could
clearly see in the previous data I hope
we can use publicly available
information to show that we are
enriching native interacting proteins
with our antibodies and if we look
closer into the mass spectrometry data
we can actually identify the peptides of
those target proteins that were
identified as well as modifications to
the sequence such as by phosphorylation
or glycosylation so very powerful
approach that provides a unique set of
information we can also quantitatively
compare antibody performance as I showed
we have a set of large number of
antibodies against we have a large large
set of antibodies that have unique
features
and understanding these by mass
spectrometry is going to provide much
more insight into how these antibodies
could be used in unique ways so I just
wanted to summarize we have at this
point we've actually screened over 600
antibodies we find overall our success
rate using immunoprecipitation of mass
spectrometry is about fifty seven
percent if an antibody has is is
annotated as validated by mass spec or
I'm sorry validated by
immunoprecipitation typically we see
seventy percent success if an antibody
does not say that it was that is
validated for immuno precipitation it's
too we typically see about forty percent
success so we're not just focused on
antibodies that have been previously
validated for mass spectrometry up as I
said immunoprecipitation of mass spec
verifies the antibody target and it
provides a great deal of additional
information about antibody performance
and this approach of using fold
enrichment provides a very simple way to
verify antibody performance and assess
interactions and off targets so this
data is just beginning to appear right
on our website now so here's an example
with p53 where we found almost over
three thousand fold enrichment of p53
with a given antibody and we see a
couple of other background proteins in
some known interactions so this we are
just beginning to to share all of these
results with our customers so if you
visit our website at thermo fisher calm
/ antibodies you'll find that we offer
more than 50,000 and beiträge and
antibodies these antibodies primary
antibodies are against know tens of
thousands of TARP you know tens of
thousands of targets and up you'll see
if you if you if in the cert if in the
top of the search screen if you just
type in a star an asterisk
and hit return will it actually the
website actually now sorts so that
proteins that have been verified using
mass spectrometry are at the top so
here's just a very simple screenshot of
some of the beta-catenin antibodies that
I've described in the last few slides
and if you click on the link for the
mass spec verified target it'll provide
more information on on the cell line and
how the antibody was used and from there
a further link takes you to a white
paper that describes our antibody
validation approach in more detail so
all of this work is actually done using
products that we sell so we didn't make
any of this stuff up we use we use the
tools that we we make for customers so
for the majority of this work we use the
mass spec compatible magnetic
immunoprecipitation kit with protein AG
with all of the buffer components we
just followed the instructions we've
done a lot of work with some of these
with these antibodies to also biotin
elate them with our biotinylation kit
and then using those biotin elated
antibodies with our streptavidin coded
magnetic beads in a similar magnetic
immunoprecipitation kit low protein
binding tubes for mass spec workflows to
eliminate losses from these low protein
amounts quantitative tools like our
color metric peptide assay so we know
how much peptide were putting on to our
mass spectrometer and for the deep
proteome analysis of those 12 different
cell lines we used our high ph reverse
phase peptide fractionation kit so we're
using the tools that we've developed
over the last number the last several
years to to build on our understanding
of our antibody portfolio so with this
I'd like to acknowledge that this is the
work of a very powerful group a group
that works for me Bob and Patel Greg
pots Lee Connor and others the help of a
bioinformatician within thermo John
Buchi that's been really the that really
helped us simplify these calculations of
fold enrichment and then working very
closely with our antibody group based
here in the U
and in Bangalore India on identifying
best practices and the the right tools
to verify our broad portfolio of
antibodies so with that I would welcome
any questions and I would like to thank
you for your for your time and I'll hand
it back over to the moderator thank you
dr. Rogers for that informative
presentation it is time for Q&A so if
you have any questions you'd like to ask
dr. Rogers please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click the send button
will answer as many questions that we
have time for okay let's get started
here our first question is dr. Rogers
why did you fold enrichment values vary
between antibodies target well I mean we
calculate fold enrichment based on the
abundance of that protein in the cell
lysate and the abundance of that protein
in the immunoprecipitated sample so as I
stated not every protein is expressed in
every cell and even if it's expressed in
two different cell lines that may be at
a different level and so we we use the
actual protein expression levels
relative to the whole cell lysate to
calculate fold enrichment so every time
we look at a different cell line or use
a different antibody and that may have a
slight difference in it in its affinity
we may see some slight difference some
differences in the fold enrichment but
we do think that fold enrichment
provides really valuable insight into
the performance of the antibody okay do
background proteins overlap between
different antibodies cell lines and how
does that affect fold in Richmond well
we actually include we don't remove the
end of the background proteins until
after we've calculated fold enrichment
because otherwise it would skew our fold
enrichment but we do it but background
proteins some of them bind to the tubes
and to the beads so
of them may bind to the antibody because
even when we use isis isotope matched we
see certain proteins that bind so it's
really going to vary of how important
those background proteins are in it just
emphasizes our need to have the right
controls Martha Rodgers flight us with
bold enrichment of interactors or
background proteins sometimes appear
greater than the actual antibody targets
well you know we showed an example with
APC where the the interacting protein
had a significantly higher fold
enrichment than the target and I guess
that refers to both the sku because that
interacting protein was so difficult to
see prior to enrichment and after
enrichment we had so much more sequence
coverage and mass spec intensity that we
had so much more signal that it showed
up as much more highly enriched so a lot
of it has to do with the the abundance
of that protein in the whole cell lysate
it also says something about the
tightness of the interaction so when a
protein like a pc has so many different
binding interaction domains for a given
target in this case beta-catenin coma i
think that also excuse it skews the fold
enrichment data to you know to much
higher levels so that's you know maybe
that's the drawback of this approach but
this is the data and you know I my goal
is to get the best data and to drive a
draw draw conclusions from that
dr. Rogers what are you going to do
about the antibodies that don't work
well that's a good question I think
we're still figuring that out we haven't
seen a lot of antibodies that don't work
on but the ones that don't what we've
done is what we're doing is collating
that list and comparing the results from
the zoom you know precipitation to mass
spec approach with other validation
approaches like si RNA or crisper
knockdown and what we're trying to do is
cut you know consolidate that
information and the goal here is to
identify antibodies that don't work so
that we can remove them from our catalog
you know we want our customers to be
happy and to be satisfied with their
with our products and so it's important
for us to to get to get rid of the bad
the bad and highlight the good now what
are the drawbacks of I PMS for antibody
verification well you know you have to
buy a mass spec so there's there's some
cost involved oh there is some there's a
little bit of expertise here but we've
tried to take a lot of that out with
some simplified kits so so there's a
method to it um I think one of the you
know in terms of the data analysis a
couple of things we found is that when
we filter with the scatter plot approach
um we actually need a couple of
different antibodies to subtract some of
the really abundant background proteins
sometimes we don't always remove those
it's I'd rather under filter than over
but sometimes we'll look at that list
and it will clearly see you know five or
six proteins like super villain or a
ribosomal protein or myosin that they
show up in other IPS but they've been
didn't necessarily get subtracted with
the control that we used so there's a
little bit there and then the other
thing that we're still struggling a
little bit with is we have a lot of
proteins that we did not see in the deep
dive all but we saw after the enrichment
and so we cannot calculate fold
enrichment for those interactors of
and you know we can it and even though
we know that you know based on the
public database or there's probably some
interaction there the problem that we've
seen is there are some proteins that we
can't calculate fold enrichment because
we never saw him in the deep dive and
that's a good or bad it's pretty
interesting so if one wants to see the
interaction between two proteins by
immunoprecipitation how can one validate
co-immunoprecipitation oh that I mean a
standard method is to cross validate so
if like I showed here if I saw
beta-catenin in my head here and pull
down I go back and see if ket hearin
shows up in my beta catenin pull down I
think that's the best strategy dr.
Rogers we have an audience member would
like to know if you could provide the
website for the RNA of NCI 16 NCI 60
yeah yeah I think it's called sell my
nurse eell mi ne are but it's a public
database of it's got are any expression
data it's got some protein at some pro
do a proto array data it's got data from
screens with different small molecule
inhibitors there's a ton of data on the
cell minor website and it's all
available for free download it's great
questions coming in today dr. Rogers do
fractions mean organellar fractionation
to enrich protein presence I know I we
have not been using organellar
enrichment when we fraction eight we are
using the high pH reverse-phase columns
and so what we do is we take the lysate
we reduce alkylate they digest with
trypsin and then we take those peptides
and we apply them to a reverse-phase
column it's actually just a little spin
column in our kit and and then we wash
you know we'd assault and then we allude
with step fractions at a high pH with
increasing amounts of acetonitrile then
we take those those fractions and dry
them down and redo solve them in our
sample buffer
and we might quantify with our peptide
ass and then we put them on to the mass
spec and we in this case we only
collected eight fractions per cell
lysate and it allowed us to more than
double the number of ident or about
double the number of identified proteins
how predictive is native IP for
performance of antibodies and WB I see
and I yet and I F well you know I think
that's yet to be determined the the
publication from elit Edwards group
showed some data with their immuno
precipitation to mass spec approach
showed that it all that many of these
antibodies also work for
immunofluorescence a few other
applications showed some data with
western blotting you know I think one of
the other applications we have not tried
yet is there are actually approaches for
denaturing your target prior to the
immuno capture we could do that we kind
of like the idea of seeing interactions
but I think there are a lot of other
ways that we could apply this strategy
to gain you know to access you know
maybe let's say we have an antibody that
only works against a denatured target I
think there are ways that we could we
could use these dis approaching in those
cases what kit did you use to immobilize
your antibody for the IP well as it
referred to in one of the later slides
we did not immobilize the antibody
frankly you know a few years ago we as
thermal Fisher and Life Technologies
merged my group we spent quite a bit of
time evaluating all of the resins that
are at the time sold by thermo
scientific and life technologies all the
dinosaurs and asked does it what's the
best approach should i immobilize my
antibody using you know epoxy or I mean
reactive beads like amino link or should
I biotin elated
I am mobilize with you know maybe I
capture with protein AG and then
crosslink it should I modify the sugars
and immobilize through glycol links we
tried all of these different approaches
and what we found was that the most
robust and frankly the best performing
method was to either use protein AG
coated beads or to biotin late the
antibody and use streptavidin it had the
highest sequence coverage and the lowest
background you know for I a wide variety
of different targets the issue that we
have with crosslinkers in an
immobilization with crosslinkers we see
some antibodies are just frankly
modified and irreparably damaged by the
cross-linker probably because there's a
lysine in the active site we have other
examples where what are the issues we
have with background proteins we want to
minimize those you know like I said we
don't have a blocker and so we want to
minimize and so what we do is we pre
incubate the antibody with the lysate we
might let that go overnight at four
degree and then we'll add to add the
beads in this case a magnetic bead and
will only give a for an hour and what we
find is that if we immobilize the
antibody we have to incubate the bead
with that antibiotic with that lysate
overnight and it's just an opportunity
for all kinds of background to develop
so we really try to separate those two
steps so that we get the best protein
you know antibody target interaction
first and then we go in and quickly grab
that interaction with our bag detik
beads Rogers can samples preserve with
tries that will be quantified using IP
mass spec I'll with tries all I know
tries all is going to completely do
nature those proteins arm and a buffer
is pretty incompatible so you know maybe
maybe if you were trying to capture
denatured targets like I said there may
be a way to do that but i think that
tries all solubilize proteins are going
to be kind of a
inaccessible with with an antibody
capture what type of mass that can be
used to characterize antibodies oh one
the one that works frankly you know it
doesn't it doesn't take a rocket
scientist this what I've shown here you
know I I'd like to think of this is it's
elegantly simple the approach that we've
taken with the background subtraction in
the fold enrichment of the only issue
that you'll have is if you're sick if
your instrument is not sensitive enough
to see the target in the in the whole
cell lysate then you're not going to be
able to calculate fold enrichment so in
this case all of these studies were done
with the Q exact of HF arm or a Q exact
of QE + a lot of some of the cell
lysates we've also run them on a
orbitrap fusion instrument but frankly
the the QEH f did it was close enough
that it was more than adequate now what
is the criteria you apply to say an
antibody antibody that is poor good or
great in I PMS is it a combination of
fold enrichment with a certain number of
interactor proteins versus off target
proteins I you know frankly this is uh
this has been a work in progress we we
started on this effort in February so
it's been a pretty pretty fast John and
I think we're still trying to figure out
what's the best what's the best antibody
we have done a little bit of work with
these these antibodies and the different
intensities that we see appears to be
dependent on the off rate the
dissociation rate constant and not
necessarily on the overall affinity
affinity is kind of weird with
antibodies because you've got two
binding domains and so the association
rate constants are affected by both of
those domains but what we do see is that
this this does seem to give an
indication of the relative off rates of
those antibodies so you won't you
basically would like to have a slow off
right
what is the equilibrium disassociation
dissociation constant KD for the
affinity purified abs you know what I
can answer that but I haven't looked i
haven't looked at the data recently
enough to be able to say what those
numbers are you know most of the i think
the the overall affinities were you know
in the low nanomolar but i don't
remember the specific numbers let's see
with so many great questions coming in
um I see dr. Rogers how long does each
ms analysis take right now we're running
what we do is we do that we do a replica
pull down so we'll do two separate pull
downs out of the lysate and process
those and we'll analyze those each one
of them is 60 or 70 minute LC run and
then we'll run a blank between samples
so it takes about two hours to analyze
the duplicates and then another half
hour to to wash off background so that
we can move on to the next antibody very
good and let's see here's another
question what are those relative off
rates oh yeah as far as the quantitative
value I again I can't remember the exact
numbers um so I i I'd have to take that
offline okay very good and then here's a
question of clarification so out of all
the approaches like cross-linking or
protein AG beads biotinylation is the
best is that so well frankly
biotinylation has is you know it's a
it's benefits and drawbacks so the
benefit is that biotinylated antibodies
have the lowest background when we
capture with those we can wash a little
bit more stringently and we can
we can use you know you can't use
protein AG and in plasma samples so if I
was trying to do immuno captures out of
plasma I wouldn't be able to use protein
AG because it'd be swamped by all the
antibody in the in the in the serum so
so we like biotinylated animal we like
using biotinylation it also allows us to
multiplex so we've done examples where
we've put together 12 different
antibodies to direct it against a whole
pathway and captured all the targets at
once using streptavidin coated beads we
don't have enough capacity and the
background is a little bit higher with
protein a cheese so there are certain
places where biotinylation really really
stands out the downside of biotinylation
is that you have to get an antibody
that's Carrie are free and you know some
of these antibodies have carrier in them
and so you have to you know request a
special order to get the antibody
without carrier so trade-offs we are
almost out of time that will have to be
our last question i would like to once
again thank dr. john rogers for his
presentation dr. Rogers you have any
final comments for our audience I know I
see uh well yeah I so my email is John
Rogers at thermo Fisher com we're we're
kind of excited about this approach it's
pretty good it's it's a new way to
characterize antibodies and frankly
right now I think we're trying to figure
out you know this work what do people
think this is going to be useful what
are the weaknesses you know we're
certainly evaluating those but i'd like
to hear other's thoughts and any
feedback thank you once again dr. John
Rogers and thank you to our sponsors
thermo fisher scientific for making
today's broadcast possible before we go
I want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through may eight 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
we thank you for joining us and hope to
see you again soon goodbye